I'm Mitch how are you I'm too blessed to
be stressed about you Dave just assumed
sir how can I help
oh we need questions for you and I know
you kind of joke about at least being a
married a year so you know how close you
want to lived here and your in-laws yeah
yes so I kind of a situation here my
in-laws are wanting to move in with us
you you lost a job out of state and they
want to move back in because of the
grandkids and stuff so kind of I wanted
your opinion on um kind of how to keep
it separate but equal if they are under
an offense my roofs on to em because it
is my in-laws and I might be a little
bit less bias and my wife are you are
you know what I'm trying to say about
how to keep it the relationship intact
but at the same time if they're going to
be paying you know rent or anything like
that if they're going to be paying real
why don't they just go round they they
went through a bankruptcy ears back and
they're they not a place for that
supposedly women if they're not a place
to pay someone else rent are they in
place to pay you rent that's a good
question too and that's maybe why I have
kind of calling you to get advice of
anything maybe a contract or something I
mean I hate to do that necessarily with
the in-laws but I don't this kind of
wanted it's not a contract in a sense of
I will sue them over the contract but
what we need is a clear understanding
here and this sounds really vague mm-hmm
like they're too broke to pay rent but
they're going to pay you rent that
sounds weird well they're selling their
house right now and they have about a
hundred fifty thousand dollars in equity
from that so so come from
so come to Phoenix and surely to God if
you have $150,000 in your pocket you can
find something to rent that I think that
is a good point as well but uh I guess I
just think kind of faux that they they
would like to move in with us
temporarily yeah I just don't think it's
a god and unless there's a compelling
reason arm I would be hesitant because
it just it doesn't usually
end well I mean there's some
circumstances where it works but I don't
get it I mean you got 150,000 bucks now
there's not a lot of hundred fifty
thousand dollar houses in Phoenix
Arizona it's a you know a substantially
you know a fairly expensive real estate
market otherwise I just but I mean it's
just two of them maybe they can find a
little condo and just pay cash for it
yeah I'm Saul so another option yeah are
they not is he not is he got a job well
he actually got let go from his entire
employer and so yeah either one line
lined up downsizing okay but he does
have another one lined up he does that's
good okay so he's going to have a job
he's got 150 thousand dollars in his
pocket mm-hmm um yes I I'm a little
confused me too I mean that's why I was
just wondering if there's something else
I mean well they'll start the stronger
the criminal is start with the premise
that I think you guys are on the wrong
track and I think they need to live
somewhere else they have $150,000 he has
a job go buy a little condo for cash
move in it it's not going to be thing
fancy for 150 grand in Phoenix but it'll
be alright it's a nice place to live
better than living in your bedroom so
for them they're going to have more
privacy and you know and have a life and
certainly they're welcome to come over
and see the grandkids we'd love to have
them do that but if ever we let them
babysit occasionally I'll be babysitting
next week for a couple mine I'm looking
forward to it
grandparents like that kind of stuff but
but that's a lot different than them
living with you for no apparent reason
I've really got to dig into this if I'm
you you and your wife need start having
some clear conversations about why we're
doing this other than they're just too
cheap to go get a hotel till they find a
place to live when does he start work um
they close on the other house here at
the end of the month and so we're
looking at you know it wouldn't be till
August timeframe of what actually down
here in Arizona again okay so they close
on the house where they're currently
living at the end of the month
exactly okay yeah that's fine and that's
when he starts his new job and
everything yep okay IIIi don't you know
you
got to dig into it maybe you find a
compelling reason let's say that
something is going on that you and I are
not aware of in this conversation and
they do want to move in then what you
want is you want a very clear
understanding of a the amount of rent
and it can just be a written letter I
mean you just type out a letter on the
computer okay bullet points and we both
sign it okay but here's the big thing I
want your exit strategy under what
circumstances and when are they leaving
yeah yeah because otherwise this is done
in like in perpetuation forever which I
don't think is your plan I don't think
it's theirs either I mean they're
wanting to you know get on their feet
until they don't know the area a little
bit better I don't know but if you want
to let them live there three months or
something while they do that that starts
to make a little bit more sense okay but
you know I don't even charge them rent
then they're just staying with you a
little while and you know and then
they're going to go get a place but this
is for three months and then they look
up at the end of three months they're
still sitting there you're going I'm
sorry what are you people doing here
yeah I wouldn't do that exactly you see
what I'm saying if you listen if they
say we're going to stay a little while
and you say okay a little while is okay
but you find out a little while to them
is two years a little while to use two
months yeah that's why you need to write
it down what is the date that you're
planning on leaving and if we decide you
and I sitting down together to decide to
change that date we can change it but at
least we've got agreement coming in if
it's just for a couple months just let
them live there it's fine yeah you're
just helping them make the transition
learn the market and go out and look for
something they're not in such a hurry to
pick out something and that kind of
thing but I got to tell you man if I was
moving to an area where my parents lived
or Sharon's parents lived we would just
rent something until we found the house
we wouldn't be moving it's just
different you know I mean there's
something else going on in this
conversation that you don't know and I
don't know that's the magnetic draw here
and it just it's just unusual so but if
you want to if it's just for a couple
months or something that's fine but if
they're talking about living there a
year they need to go rent something or
they need to just take the 150,000 and
go find something
but you know I've got the money and the
goodness gracious I got the money I
don't care if there's a bankruptcy a
couple years ago they're in good shape
hey thanks for the call man I appreciate
you joining us hey you guys Rachael Cruz
here hope you are enjoying the Dave
Ramsey show and did you know that I have
my very own YouTube channel yes that's
right it's kind of better than the Dave
Ramsey channel don't tell them I said
that
I'm kidding I'm kidding so subscribe and
there's lots of videos about life and
money so while you're at it if you want
to check out a video then you can check
out how to do a monthly budget it's one
of the best videos out there
you